I'm Brad McManus and this is build your
squad I got 15 dollars to build my
all-time favorite chiefs and 49er squad
okay so it's a great list here of
players and you know I'll start with the
quarterback because obviously they get
things going Joe Montana was great Steve
Young was great but at the value of $3
so I got to go with Patrick in my homes
and he's incredible star MVP last year
he's got him back to the Super Bowl so
three dollars down the drain there you
got $12 left running back his toe I mean
these are some great great names I think
Marcus Allen I still think he had some
juice down there you know was it the
Chiefs Oh a Hall of Famer himself time
ago of Marcus Allen hyuna's in the back
end his career he still was an awesome
awesome flare two more dollars down the
drain my fly dogs got $10 left we got
receivers or tight ends here a Hall of
Famer Hall of Famer Hall of Famer
immaculate catch and future superstar
here Tyree kill for the value at $1 the
speed he's got
I gotta go with Tyree kill her one more
dollar I know it's cheap but sorry one
dollar toss and then imma skip the
corner to see how much money I left but
Derek Thomas is a special special player
you know all-time great he hit my boy
bought Miller I'm best friends with you
know idolized Derek Thomas and so I got
to get five dollars for him so call some
costly but he was he's an all-time great
so there's five more they have four
dollars left for the safety check over
my man Eric Berry here recovered from
cancer incredible player deserves
everything he needs to and
with one of the best safeties ever so
that's $15 some all-time 49ers Chiefs
team
I got quarterback bachelor homes Tyree
kill Marcus Allen Derrick Thomas and
Eric Barry I just realized they're all
Chiefs let's apologize 49ers fans but
this is my all-time $15 squad